- [Instructor] A 1,900 kilogram truck
has an initial speed of
12 meters per second.
The driver applies the brakes
and the truck stops in 3.1 seconds.
What is the best estimate
of the magnitude of the average
braking force on the truck?
Pause this video, see if
you can work this out.
All right, probably the
simplest way to approach this
is to say, well we could figure out
the magnitude of the acceleration,
the average acceleration on that truck
as it comes to a stop.
And then we could use Newton's second law,
F equals ma
'cause we know its mass.
And if we know the mass
and the magnitude of the acceleration,
we could use Newton's second law
to come up with the magnitude
of the average braking force.
And they just want us to estimate it.
And we can see that these
choices are pretty far apart.
So an estimate will serve us well.
So first let's think
about the acceleration.
The acceleration
is going to be our change in velocity
over change in time.
And so that's just going
to be our final velocity
minus our initial velocity, the numerator.
So our final velocity is
zero meters per second.
We come to a stop.
Minus our initial velocity,
that's 12 meters per second.
And the convention that we'll assume,
and is typical,
is that if we're moving to
the right, it's positive,
if we're moving to the
left, it's negative.
And so it's moving to the
right at 12 meters per second
so we're subtracting that
positive velocity out.
So this is our change in velocity
over our change in time.
Well, 3.1 seconds elapses.
So over 3.1 seconds.
And so what is this going to be
approximately equal to?
Well, let's see.
Negative 12 over 3.1
is going to be approximately four.
And once again, I am estimating.
It might be a little bit closer to,
oh, and it's going to be
approximately equal to negative four.
It might be a little bit
closer to negative 3.9,
around there.
But I'll go with negative four.
And then the units are
meters per second squared.
And now we use Newton's
second law to take this
to think about the magnitude
of the braking force.
Which is going to be,
and this makes sense that
the acceleration is negative
that our velocity's in this direction
but our acceleration is
in the other direction,
it is slowing down.
We're getting lower and
lower and lower velocities.
And so our force is going
to be the same direction,
our net force is in the same
direction as that acceleration.
It's going to be to the left.
So if we had a sign on it,
it would be negative.
But we just care about the magnitude.
So when we think about
Newton's second law,
we'll also just look at the
magnitude of the acceleration.
So Newton's second law,
the magnitude of the force,
needs to be equal to
the mass times the magnitude
of the acceleration.
So this is going to be equal to,
this is,
let me write an approximation here.
Because I approximated this.
It's going to be
approximately 1,900 kilograms
times four meters per second squared.
I didn't feel the need to
write the negative there
'cause I just wanna get the magnitude.
I care about absolute value right now.
So if I do this,
this is going to be approximately what?
7,600 kilograms.
Now if I look at the choices,
I don't see 7,600,
but the closest one over here is 7,400.
And I feel good about that
because the real value
here might be closer
to negative 3.9 meters per second squared
and if this was 3.9 right over here,
3.9 times 1,900,
well that gets us a lot
closer to this right here.
So I like this choice.
And all the other ones are
way off from our estimate.